whoever had the inspiration to cast you
as zach galifianakis 'as mom i think
that's the most genius casting that i've
encountered and you do it beautifully
thank you hurry thanks so much you're
great and I'm so thrilled for you that
that's been recognized people thank you
universally you've exact who really said
he said to the producer he goes uh well
what is what's the mom like and he goes
well I just know it's a sound anyway and
that the producer said you mean Lois
Anderson yeah
and they said should we call them and
they called me and they said would you
do apart Anzac sitcom and I go yeah yeah
would you play the mother clip here we
have a clip there and you know what's
what I love so much is that so many
people if they're going to play the mom
it's a guy playing the mom they would
make an over-the-top choice right you
don't do that at all you act it
beautifully and and you just you just
morph into this person we have a clip
here from baskets I think Zack is coming
home you're with a gentleman caller I
believe yes my boyfriend yeah I would
say gentleman caller Shakespeare I'm
very yes actually yes my bow your bow
with that did not use your name my mom
watches the show so I like to use yes
those aren't afraid someone caller
gentleman caller and you both they're
holding your cats I think in this scene
and playing holding Ronald Reagan yeah
you're guessing you're both pretending
you're cats talk because that's a night
it's a sweet scene let's take a look at
this scene from baskets hi my name is
Susan I'm very happy to be here what is
your name I'm Ronald Regan just call me
Ronnie I love your face it's so unusual
I'm from Colorado and I've never lived
with another cat before well you'll be
fine here because my mom loves cats
doesn't she okay oh yeah Dvorak are you
what my car keys baskets
season 4 premieres tomorrow at 10:00 on
FX and it is a delight and Louie
Anderson we're always it's just it's a
it's a thrill to have you on the show
you're so thank you you're hilarious and
a great guy Louie Anderson
[Applause]